[Music]
I think through a lot of different
factors I came together for stage 19 to
to really take place the start of the
Giro over in Jerusalem I had crashed in
the the Recon of the time trial and
before the race even begun some crashes
you get up from and brush it off and
you're fine but this one I wasn't right
I wasn't right and I felt for at least
the first 10 days of the race I just
wasn't myself I felt out of balance out
of synch and I I was hemorrhaging time I
was I was losing time at every
opportunity pretty much lets across we
knew that copy crashes Chris Froome is
down Chris room has had a torrid opening
to this talk I found myself coming into
stage 19 over three minutes down and I
knew it would take something absolutely
crazy to turn the race upside down and
it would be a kind of move of almost a
suicide move would be all or nothing
that idea of going solo ATK's out was a
decision I made in the morning before
the race I sent a message to my coach in
Karason and just said to him it's a bit
of a bit of a crazy move but what do you
think if I went ATK's out there's only
three climbs two descents it's going to
be a Time Trial and behind that they
could have to sort out a really good
chase if if they want to catch me I mean
and he replied and his reply was a
little bit along the lines of he didn't
say no but he said listen it would take
a lot of work to do something like that
I mean it was it was going to be a one
of the biggest days on the bike in my
life in terms of energy expenditure so
how do I feel for a stage like that I
had to think about how much fuelling I
need to get in before the race and then
again once I got into the race
how often do I feel and
on what and basically going at a time
trial as hard as I could certainly that
word out it's something that could go
completely wrong and you know what if it
doesn't work out then you lose
everything
but on the other side I was also
thinking about it as well I'm feeling
good I'm feeling better in myself now
I'm gonna get out there and go into time
trial mode as things developed out on
the road Simon Yates had started
dropping easy right near the back yeah
extra cozy that's not good that's not
good we hit the foot of the the finestra
and the team I asked the guys to ramp it
up through all the hair pins earlier on
and make the race harder and harder so
for the guys further back there would
have been quite tough already they're
racing we start they're not just riding
tempo they're actually they're attacking
they are bracing this climb at the top
on the hardest section now Yates was
dropped through Milan had started losing
teammates already
and I think only at that point that I
did I really believe okay I'm gonna do
this now this is the moment it's now or
never
through now he goes on the offensive he
goes on the attack over the top of this
final climate
it's just an amazing feeling to see that
do my line and the other TC guys they
want on their that that was that was
where the the time trial started four
times a winner of the Tour de France
winner of the world took a team every
year to do a d'Italia victory once I
accelerated and I saw no one come with
me I just stuff it I'm gonna go for it
now all or nothing and get stuck into
this and even on this descent he's
taking it
I wouldn't say I was taking risks on the
descents but I pushed on and went as
fast as I could
it was just an amazing feeling to get to
the bottom of the descent into the next
Valley and just hear that the gap it
opened up another 30 40 seconds just in
which is almost for free like this is
not really much pedaling to do on its
end it's more about the technique in the
lines you take as the race went on and
that that gap went up from one minute in
one a half to two and a half three and
it was just like wow I'm now in in in
reach of pink jersey and the overall
lead of the race Chris Froome is now the
virtual leader the valley of Rosa of
this jewett Italian what a stage it has
been being out in front has changed he
gave me even more I guess to to fight
for there is the boat Amalia motor on
the road
at the start of today what
today was about fuelling and today was
about making sure that you can fuel a
ride like this all the way through to
the end another is fundamental and so
all the members are staff every single
one of them myself included they now
decide their own and put in place a
fuelling plan for him to make sure that
he would absolutely not miss a beat
because that that's basically the game
changer it's certainly not easy to take
on that amount of carbohydrates every
opportunity I had I'll be putting
something else in my mouth and I think
the beta fuel played a huge part in that
obviously it's it's just a drink it's in
a bottle but you get 80 grams of carbs
from one bottle and I think I had two
beautiful drinks are on the road and I
literally went into the stage so full
already I think I was just just bursting
I felt as if I I literally cannot eat
any more right now but thankfully that's
the way I went into the race because
certainly when when I crossed that
finish line at the end I was completely
empty I had nothing left so I'm pretty
glad that I did fill up in that way
Chris Froome is gonna ride into Rome in
the pictures of the dirt this picture of
me is completely unique I've never
attacked it to gaze out and I mean it's
just something that you don't really see
very often anymore in professional
cycling it's just been a couple decades
since we since we saw someone win a
Grand Tour in that kind of fashion this
is the moment that we've been waiting
for Chris Froome is the winner of the
hundred and first edition of the Giudice
[Applause]
[Music]